right now as we are
live right now in downtown portland
there is uh
a rally a set of rallies and a set of
counter rallies in downtown portland
uh between basically um right-of-center
protesters and left-of-center protesters
and i don't i
i think that um at least one of the
groups right of center
is the proud boys and certainly one of
the groups left to center is
black lives matter and antifa that's
like two groups
with tight uh correlation um and
they are you know right now um meeting
on the streets of portland
squaring off which is something that
they have done regularly they
effectively announce one group announces
that it will be there the other group
announces that it will show up
and things um unfold from there i should
say i've attended one of these just to
see what it looked like on both sides
and um in general uh it is a contained
version of what is now uncontained
in portland but i would we'll we'll hear
about it we'll find out um but
i'll bet that today's events are not as
contained in part
um this is uh this is one of the first
times that the people from the right
have declared
uh in advance that they're going to show
up for a while certainly i think
i may be wrong about this but certainly
the first time maybe in this 80 plus
days that the riots have been nightly
in portland and maybe um you know if
they showed up it was
at all it's been it was early unless so
um on august 20th today is the
22nd so two days ago we received an
email from a viewer
of this live stream who lives in north
portland which is two blocks from the
police union building
on north lombard that has been at the
center of some of the protests and riots
in portland so there's sort of
four lar broad areas not large areas but
sort of four
buildings really that the protesters and
then the rioters have
have targeted and um the police building
on north lombard in in north portland
has been one of them so this is a viewer
who lives just a couple blocks from that
building
and he said yesterday these pamphlets
were placed on the front porches in my
neighborhood it's blatant propaganda and
some of the verbiage is disconcerting at
best
so i just he included uh screenshots and
not screenshots he took pictures and he
showed
us that so um we're going to show you
the zack would you show
the first of those four pictures from
the um yep and maybe just make a little
bigger so people can
can see it a little bit more okay it's
it's fine
okay so that's the that's the cover um
next page uh
somewhere on this uh we can't we we
can't read this but somewhere on this it
says
do not expect peace from the police a
fundamentally violent institution which
functions to suppress effective social
movements
that's a claim next page
somewhere on this page it says night
after night police respond with violent
escalation regardless of protesters
actions
another claim i think unfounded
and final page how you can help on the
ground you can leave water bottles out
for protesters you can provide verbal
support from your homes most importantly
you could join us on the streets
there is strength in numbers the more
people there are out on the streets
the less likely it is that the cops will
injure people
so just one more thing before i ask us
to talk about this a little bit zach if
you would show the video
um that i asked you to show from
north portland last night
[Music]
so that is by far not the
most violent of the videos from the
nighttime
protests slash riots in fact there is no
real violence there though you might
understand there'd be a threat of
violence but what they're saying
is out of your house and into the street
out of your house and into the street
which is of course quite not what they
suggested
in their pamphlet that they were
distributing to exactly this
neighborhood the day before
they were asking you to voice support
from your house which is itself an ask
that is
potentially a big one because it would
appear to be a kind of
payment that you must give whether or
not you believe it
but the very next day what the what the
protesters
who might later become rioters are doing
is demanding
that you not merely show support from
the safety of your own home but you get
onto the streets with them
so there's a trope built in here that
were you to see it in different context
everybody would get it 100
which is the veiled
threat yeah it's not even a threat with
plausible deniability it's implausible
deniability where a threat is leveled
but it's done in a way that is
unprovable
you can't tell for sure that it's a
threat not at the level that it would
be required to prosecute somebody for it
but it's obviously a threat from the
point of view of the person
hearing it and so you know so out of
your homes and into the streets
that's a demand a demand being
shouted by people shining very powerful
lights
into people's homes imagine you were at
home and
an angry crowd that is setting fires
nightly in portland
is outside your house breaking into into
buildings police precincts yep night
after night
um and you know well
you could report this as uh protesters
marched through neighborhoods and
you know invited homeowners to join them
i'm sure it's been reported that way
i'm sure to the extent it's been
reported at all and i must say people
around the world who we're in contact
with have the sense that things are
calming down in portland
i see no evidence of that nope it's hard
to know because you have to
the protests are so concentrated that
it's not like the evidence is you know
we don't encounter it on the way to the
market or
the post office or whatever but we were
sure things would calm down once
the governor and the mayor negotiated
that the feds would leave so long as
state and local police came forward and
started doing their jobs
right they're not being allowed to no
but the point is okay so that's a
that's a implausibly deniable threat the
shining of bright lights into people's
windows
um and consistency that's
that's on the cusp of deniability right
uh is that could you show the one that i
had the similar looking
video from one of the last couple of
nights
now this one uh
we cannot here wake up wake up
wake up [ __ ]
here we go
wake up wake up wake up [ __ ]
wake up okay right
now that doesn't sound like an
invitation
not really now it could be uh a
temporally inappropriate wake-up call i
mean as long as we're doing
plausible or implausible deniability
maybe they think the people of north
portland are nocturnal
right who knows um but the point is
that's very threatening stuff
it's threatening to anybody who sees it
a lot will rest on the fact that you're
not likely to see that if you're tuned
into certain accounts on twitter you'll
see it you could
you know you could subscribe to those
accounts and you can see the stuff from
every single night
or the few accounts that those videos
are coming from
have been uh have been described
as unreliable because they report
the same kind of story all the time as
if
reporting the same kind of story all the
time itself makes you unreliable
when actually it's because we've got 86
87
nights now of uninterrupted
uninterrupted
and you know i'm i can't be certain of
this but i think that from the point
that
violence showed up uh late it's been
consistent every night there's been
at least some so okay you've got a
situation in which if you're tuned into
certain
uh if you're tuned in let's say for
example to
the portland subreddit
the portland subreddit is quite
consistent
in reporting um that peaceful
protesters are out working hard
and uh being attacked by police
um ezra would be led to believe by that
pamphlet right
so basically you've got two stories
they're completely incompatible with
each other
right and one of them is just uh
absolutely insistent on the fact that
this is about
racial injustice that the demands are
reasonable
that the response is unreasonable well
and i mean there's just a couple of
tropes again
uh phrases even that you see repeated
over and over again that seem to have
lodged themselves in people's brain
and that are just very effective mostly
peaceful
the vast majority of the time you can go
and you don't see violence
and in this particular case the fact
that you can predict it based on time of
night and
you know position of sun in the sky uh
makes that an even less compelling
argument than it would be otherwise but
who who cares you know most war zones on
you know an average
moment don't look like there's much
going on right right
and most actually this is maybe this is
too far afield i won't
like won't land for people watching but
i used to make this point when i would
teach animal behavior anyway i had
all these students streaming in i love
animals i really want to
watch animals do what they do and i say
okay you're going i'm gonna
i'm gonna you know have you be in the
field doing animal behavior and you are
going to recognize how boring most of it
is because
for the most part animals sit around
doing nothing just like humans do as
animals right
you know think about your own last 24
hours or a week
you know how often were you doing the
sort of thing that you would be excited
to see an animal doing
um you know and this you know the the
moments
and for humans you know maybe eating
would count because that would be
uh you know prey capture in a carnivore
but it would just be browsing if you're
watching if you're doing deer behavior
um you know how often are they actually
like having sex or engaging in
territorial interactions
or you know feeding their chicks it
happens not very much
and so the vast majority of time is
spent
in this sort of you know resting state
just like with these protests that
become riots reliably
so we have not talked about this in
advance but of course i was
thinking the very same thing and i did a
few back of the envelope calculations
really yeah it turns out i don't i don't
i don't see anything world war one
was 81 peaceful 81
yeah yeah world war ii you got the
receipts for world war ii was more than
85
peaceful and here's the one that really
blew my mind world war ii was was more
peaceful in the world worldwide it was
more peaceful
um the uh presidential motorcade in
dallas in 1963 was 99.8
peaceful it's just that one moment just
a very brief moment of not
peace yeah um so anyway yes these
calculations about how peaceful
something is can be very
misleading if you're not paying
attention to the objective which
actually is to wield power well
and i'm banging this drum all the time
but it's another form of innumeracy like
oh mostly peaceful
mostly doesn't mean when you think it
means there it's doing a job that is
rhetorical that is political is
achieving a goal
it's not actually describing something
that is meaningful in the way that you
think it is
yeah it describes nothing and it's it's
obviously completely preposterous it's a
phony story here
um and so all right um
the fact of us being unable to agree on
the basic facts of what is taking place
if you're paying attention to the
portland subreddit you get the sense
that there are protesters who are
under attack by the police that that's
what's going on
if you're paying attention to andy no or
this account uh bg on the scene who's
been documenting these things
that's where that first video was from
yeah you have a very different
impression now the fact is
the portland subreddit read it cannot
martial evidence
that these protests are peaceful in
light of the fact that what they do is
fail to report the part that isn't
peaceful so that's not really
it's verificationist it's
verificationist on the other hand
uh andy noe and bg on
the scene and these other accounts that
have documented this have
shown you evidence now it is possible
and i'm not saying that these accounts
do this it is possible to misrepresent
this as what is going on across portland
which is not true
or to you know or to show evidence of
pro
of rioters being violent and not to show
evidence of police being violent that is
certainly a way
that uh that those videos could be
cherry-picked to create a narrative that
is not true right it could be
cherry-picked on the other hand there's
certain stuff here that's just
very completely unambiguous and if you
have done what we've done which is check
in on what's going on in portland
it's very clear what's going on you have
a peaceful protest that precedes a riot
the riot is reliable
it involves arson it now involves
harassing people in their own
homes it involves breaking and entering
let's see zach do you want to put up the
the fire
so we have nightly fires this one i
believe is from last
night again this is uh vg on the scene
this is a
what did that lime scooter ever do to
them uh yes this was falsely reported as
a bird scooter it has now been corrected
to alignment oh i got it right
you did get it right you nailed it oh
that that is some reporting on the
ground right there
false reporting is the wrong kind of
scooter wrong brand a scooter yeah but i
mean here's the thing okay these things
are being lit on fire
um trash cans are repeatedly being lit
on fire
this is actually releasing toxins into
people's
neighborhoods this stuff actually gets
breathed by people sure as well but what
it's also doing is releasing pent up
energy
well sure and this you know so the the
cover story is one that some of the
people engaged in this behavior actually
believe
and it is nearly impossible
for people in the midst of such
activities
especially emerging as they have after
i mean at this point the protests and
riots have been going on for longer than
the lockdowns did before they started
which is which is amazing i remember
when they started it felt like well this
is how the end of lockdown
will reveal itself like no we're still
you know still in portland we're still
in
phase one or something of of reopening
and you know the schools are staying
virtual in all of this
um but people
people who are engaging this and even
most of the rest of us
cannot begin to fathom how much of this
is about the manifestation of a mental
health crisis
a mental health crisis that is only
going to get worse here you know here we
are
in the northern temperate zone and
indeed for those of you who aren't in
the pacific northwest who have this
image of it being rainy all the time
we truly have the most beautiful summers
on the planet brett and i have been
you're not all over the planet but a lot
of places and there is
no place else we'd rather be uh july
august september it is
it is gorgeous and you know it has it
this year has been a little bit weird
but um
you know in general clear blue skies and
80 degrees and
you know going down to 50 at night and
no humidity and just completely gorgeous
and it will become dark and cold
and rainy and depressing soon the days
are getting short
fast shorter faster now than they have
been
and the election is coming
what is this going to look like the only
thing
that will keep the stuff going on the
streets in check is the fact that it
will be
harder for people to motivate to leave
their homes when it's
gross and cold outside but this this is
peak beauty here in the pacific
northwest it does make it easiest to get
out there but it's also the moment when
people are probably
at their mental health peak in general
in the year
and there's no end in sight to lockdowns
to virtual schooling to to being able to
go back to
live theater live music bars
clubs hanging out in restaurants inside
safely you know hanging out at
restaurants outside you know it's
pretty safe and i know some of the
restaurants are open inside but
it's probably not safe so what what is
going to happen
it's it is it is a toxic toxic brew you
you said you know it's going to release
toxins when when they're setting fire to
the stuff yes it is
but it's also this release of energy
that is not in and of itself healthy
but is also not fully released yeah we
are we are headed for a calamity here
um zach can you put up the uh public
service announcement video
it shouldn't be that way honestly we
should be getting paid because we're
working so [ __ ] hard
so donate to us make sure these things
keep happening
and you keep coming out here and getting
more angry every day because black
people are still getting killed whether
you see it on the news or not
so i think we're dead so in that video
the person making the announcement makes
the claim and it's very familiar to us
from what happened at evergreen
uh in fact a lot of this is and i've
seen people comment on
what is he saying uh she is saying um
that the protesters should be
paid for what they're doing um
and there is this sense yeah you know
there's
it's just it's either a complete
lie or it is a level of
delusion that is almost inconceivable
you